- [Instructor] So we have this circle
called circle O,
based on the point at its center,
and we have the segment OD,
and we're told that segment OD,
is a radius of circle O, fair enough.
We're also told
that segment OD is
perpendicular to this chord
to chord AC, or two segment AC.
And what we wanna prove is
that segment OD bisects AC.
So another way to think about it,
it intersects AC at AC's midpoint.
So pause this video and see if
you can have a go with that.
All right, now let's go
through this together.
And the way that I'm going to do this,
is by establishing two
congruent triangles.
And let me draw these triangles.
So I'm gonna draw one
radius going from O to C
and another from A to O.
Now we know that the
length AO is equal to OC
because AO and OC, both radii.
In a circle, the length of
the radius does not change.
So I can put that right over there.
And then we also know that OM
is going to be congruent to itself,
it's a side in both of these triangles.
So let me just write it this way.
OM is going to be congruent to OM
and this is reflexivity.
Reflexivity kind of obvious.
It's going to be equal to itself,
it's going to be congruent to itself.
So you have it just like that.
And now we have two right triangles.
How do I know they're right triangles?
Well, they told us
that segment OD is
perpendicular to segment AC
and our assumptions in our given.
Now if you just had two triangles,
that had two pairs of congruent sides
that is not enough to establish
congruency of the triangles.
But if you're dealing
with two right triangles,
then it is enough.
And there's two ways to think about it.
We had thought about the RSH postulate
where if you have a right triangle
or two right triangles,
you have a pair of sides are congruent,
a pair and the hypothesis are congruent
that means that the two
triangles are congruent.
But another way to think about it,
which is a little bit of common sense is
using the Pythagorean theorem.
If you know two sides of a right triangle,
the Pythagorean theorem would tell us
that you could determine
what the other side is.
And so what we could say is
and let's just use RSH for now,
but you could also say we can
use the Pythagorean theorem
to establish that AM is
going to be congruent to MC,
but let me just write it this way.
I will write that triangle,
AMO is congruent to triangle CMO by RSH.
And if the triangles are congruent
then the corresponding
sides must be congruent.
So, therefore, we know that AM,
AM, segment AM is going to be,
I'm having trouble writing congruent
is going to be congruent to segment CM,
that these are going to
have the same measure.
And if they have the same measure,
we have just shown that
M is the midpoint of AC
or that OD bisects AC.
So, let me just write it that way.
Therefore, OD bisects AC.
Segment OD bisects
segment AC and we're done.